hello everyone and welcome to the most
requested game
uh you guys have sent me a since it uh
ended uh it's alexander garcia
versus alexandra costano from the fide
women's world cup 2021 it's a really an
incredible game features a lot of cool
moments there will be two positive video
moments so
you know stay tuned for that uh and
let's check it out it's really really an
awesome one
so uh now with the white pieces opens
with
d4 uh with knight to f6 c4
that's not a c4 uh c4 e6 uh
g3 and now d5 so striking in the center
we have a catalan opening bishop to g2
and the d
captures and c4 so all very very
standard stuff knight f3 we have a6 here
and now castle by white we have knight
to c6
and now usually white just continues
with e3 here but here we have bishop to
e3 it's a very rare continuation it's
only been played a few times
and this is what a gorilla cannot
chooses as a surprise for uh for
kusteniuk
so here knight to d5 going after this
weirdly placed
bishop right away queen to c1 defending
and now
uh there are a couple of games where
bishop to e7 and bishop to d7 were
played but here we have knight captures
on e3
and it's already as of move eight that
we have a completely new game so it kind
of makes sense you want to
grab the bishop pair why not but it's
it's also kind of playing right into
white's preparation
so bishop captures an e3 bishop queen
captures an e3 bishop to e7 and
now rook to c1 preparing to win back the
pawn
and you can't defend it with b5 because
the standard knight the e5 idea
uh jumps uh you know uh into mind so
rook c1 we have cas
castles by black and now rook captures
on c4 so winning back at the pawn
bishop to d7 continuing development and
now
a3 preparing b4 so black prevents this
we have a5
and now knight b to d2 uh with a4 now
grabbing more space on the queen side
preparing knight a5 to
to b3 uh so knights to e5 now
uh putting pressure on the knight here
and if this knight moves maybe we can
pick up the
the b7 pawn so knights to a5 but uh here
knight also defends it so it's not a
problem
and attacks the rook here on c4 so the
rook has to move and now
bishop to b5 so the bishop gets
activated
uh as it wasn't doing all that much on
d7 and black really wants to keep the
bishop pair
here it's nicely controlling the knight
and well there's no way for white to to
attack it
and it's pressuring the e2 pawn and the
queen wants to move
from here at some point because you want
to push this pawn to e3 or e4
so here we have rook to e1 making room
for the queen to
uh to move so the rook will be defending
the e2 pawn we rook to a6 this is how
we're gonna
develop our queen side rook and now h4
preparing further expansion on the king
side h5h6
we have rook to d6 now with a double
attack on the d4 pawn but
uh white doesn't defend white just
counter attacks with queen to c3 now
going after the c7 pawn
so castano defends with c6 and now e3 so
everything is perfectly fine for both
wine white and black
and now it's uh it's a question how are
you going to continue this game with
black one way is to play queen c7 and
bring the rook over to d8
but costano chooses a different approach
you place
f6 now it's always uh you know crazy
when
when f6 gets played you know it weakens
the king side but sometimes it
grants you more control over the center
because it's never pleasant playing with
this knight on e5 so she decided to kick
it
away right away knight e to f3 you could
also maybe go to d3 then later on to c5
maybe but
uh she decides to bring it back to f3
and now
e5 attacking uh in the center but this
doesn't really work
but it's uh it's very interesting why
not
so you might even want to try and pause
the video here and try to figure out why
it doesn't work
uh because it's uh it's actually a
really cool line so
you know while i give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations as i know that's the
first move that you thought of
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's b4
there are other moves you can play in
this position but this one
is just uh the coolest because it really
shows why e5 is
bad on the spot the problem is you you
can't play something like he captures on
d4
because uh if you lose your chance to
play uh
captures on b3 alpason then you're not
going to be able to play it anymore and
the knight has no squares to retreat to
so here we have to go uh with this idea
a captures on b3 alpha
knight and uh of course you can play d
captures on e5
uh uh sorry uh instead of b4 uh if you
try something like d
captures on e5 let's not forget that uh
rook to d3 just wins the queen forgot to
mention that
uh so yeah b4 just attacking we have
eight captures on b3 alpha
knight captures knight captures and
queen captures with
king h8 and now a4 challenging the
bishop here bishop to a6 and now d
captures on e5 uh goriachina says thank
you for the free pawn so this is how
you nicely win a pawn uh we have rook to
d3 now
attacking the white queen but now rook
the c3 we have characters captures
f captures on e5 and now queen captures
an e5 capturing the pawn
while very nicely centralizing your
queen so now white is
up upon but black still has the bishop
fair and
the past c pawn so usually computers may
favor white here
a human might favor even black here
because of the bishop pair in the past
pawn
so uh here we have h5 uh sorry first c5
black of course starts uh advancing the
past pawn and now
h5 the idea is of course h6 and queen
captures with checkmate
black of course will not allow this so
c4 continuing to push the pass pawn with
h6 now threatening checkmate
bishop to f6 and now h captures and g7
with
check bishop captures and now queen to
h5 preparing knight to g5 and
if you start pushing right away knight
g5 is just deadly because
you know h6 knight to f7 check it's game
over
so instead we have queen to f6 uh and
now still knights to g5 it seems like
you shouldn't be playing knights to g5
here but that's exactly what goriach
gonna plays
now again threatening checkmate even
allowing queen captures on f2
and here you have to play queen to g6 is
the only move that continues the game
for black
the problem is uh you know you're left
with a with a
very bad position so here uh uh question
you played queen captures on f2
it's in fact the losing move but that's
why chess is fun with king the h2
now comes queen to c2 guarding checkmate
and now of course a move that everyone
plays at e4 we block
the the queens um reach the dh7 pawn
uh and now we have to play h6 we have to
defend against checkmate
and now this is the position that
everyone has been discussing and
everyone's been talking about this
position so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only winning idea for white
while i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting
knight to e6 because this is not winning
but it's also a fine move it might be
winning in the in a very long run
but uh you know if you found this then
it's fine
knight to f7 uh is what was actually
played in the game but the move that
wins the game on the spot is rook to d1
incredible move uh now you uh you don't
really have a move here
there's nothing that black can play
there's no move that you could make and
it's such a
such a such a helpless position for
black
uh to give you an example let's say you
try rook f2 you go after the bishop here
we just deliver a check rook d8
check and okay we go back with the rook
but now we play rook to d6
and again what do you play here if you
try this again you go after the bishop
we just play
knight f7 check king to g8 and now rook
the eighth check the f7 square is
guarded
and once the king goes back knight to g5
is checkmate so
that's one way to do it another way if
of course black is not interested in uh
moving the rook from the back rank i
mean why would he
uh you might play something like queen
to b2 but now
uh yes you are helping out with the
defense here but now just
e5 and now the bishop cannot capture
because we capture on h6 and
uh well what what do you do here there
there is no good move that
that you can make here for example uh if
you capture with the queen uh we just
played knight to f7 check
now we fork the king and the queen and
now after rook captures we first deliver
check rook to d8 check rook to f8 rook
capture sun fade
bishop captures uh or even not not
bishop captures uh we're going to play
king
the h7 first uh and then queen to f7
this is how we can do it because if you
uh if after rook captures bishop
captures uh then of course you lose the
queen
so we have to play this now queen f7 and
now this is of course uh
completely winning for white let's say
c3 you start pushing your pawn
rook to d8 now you play c2 now we play
bishop to e for
check incredible uh sacrificing the
bishop like this
uh the queen captures queen to ga to
check king to g6 now rook to d6 with
check and now the king is in a in a
mating web king f5 or wherever it
doesn't really matter queen f7 checking
the g4 rogue g6 check
and now you have to go uh here on under
the mask and now let's say rook g7
opens up a discovery queen to g6 only
move there's nothing you can play queen
captures will be checkmate
so after rook to d1 there is nothing
that black can play no
piece uh black can move it's just dead
lost for
for for black but it's uh also not a
move you play easily because it's uh
uh it's it seems like it's doing nothing
but it but it's doing everything it's
uh it has to be on an open line uh so
here
knight stays seven also fine and we're
actually gonna play knight to f7 check
but now
black gets uh you know a new lease on
life so king the g8 attacking the knight
queen to d5 now threatening some very
nasty discoveries but here
uh kostanyuk just ignores white and
plays c3
saying okay do your discoveries we have
knight captures on h6
uh a discovery now from the queen and
also a check from the knight
king h7 knight back to f7 and
now comes queen to f2 so with a double
attack on the knight
uh and now what do you play here uh the
only way to
to kind of keep this uh a draw is queen
to h5 check
king ga tonight delivers check bishop
captures queen captures
and now you will be able to draw this
the rook cannot be captured because of
this
uh uh perpetual checking maneuver
and whatever else you do it's still
still gonna be a draw
but in the game nights the g5 check was
played and now for the third and final
time even though i said it was going to
be two times it's actually three times
pause the video and win the game for
black while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on always going
forward with your king that's how games
are won
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's king the g6 that's
the good stuff and now
what do you play here white has to play
something and
it's not it's not easy finding a move
because well the
the rook is uh still attacked here on d1
so what can you play rook the h1 was
played kind of trying to maybe
make use of the h file if the queen ever
moves from f2 but now
queen to d4 kostanik now just offers a
queen trade and she says okay my past
pawn will be
sufficient so knight's the h3 preparing
to shift the knight over to f4
uh and now queen captures on d5 we have
e captures on the e5 now
also white's pass pawn is on d5 already
bishop to h6 now guarding the queening
square and this bishop is coming to d3
so both of the squares should be covered
so rook the e1 and now of course you can
play c2 right away because bishop
e4 check picks up the pawn so here we
have bishop to d3 first
and now knight of course will uh
eliminate one of the bishops
either the bishop and e3 or you give up
your own bishop for the knight
so bishop captures that you have to play
this or you could play rook captures and
try and play this with
with the bishop pair but of course
bishop capture seems more natural
g captures we have rook captures and now
d6
white starts pushing the pass pawn rook
capture sunny for
bishop characters on b7 and now rook to
d4 putting the rogue behind the pass
pawn
king to g3 we have bishop to f5 now are
now ready to push the pawn and the
bishop to
f3 we have c2 rook to c1 now you can't
allow a move like rook to d1
you would happily give up your rook for
for the queening of the c pawn
so rook to c1 and now king to f6 now
we're going after this pawn
king f2 we're gonna play king to e5 and
here we have king to e3 and this is the
move that really allowed the black to go
go for the win uh this is such a tricky
position i'm gonna show you a really
cool
cool idea and that is d7 uh the idea is
that if the bishop captures we just
capture on c2
and if the rook captures then we play
bishop to g4
and uh well then we then we uh uh fight
this to a draw a bishop captures real
captures and then we have a rook against
the rook and bishop
uh there are many many positions of of
this end game
most famous ones being the the
philadelphia and the lowly position but
uh uh this is not either of them or you
know
one of the known winning positions so
maybe i don't know if this is winning i
don't think it's winning
uh it should not be winning so this was
one way to do it but here we have king
the e3
and now it's a little bit easier because
now rook to d3
check pushes the king back and now rook
captures on d6 and now
now it's much different now you don't
have bishop g4 because there's no rook
on d7
and also it it you know the bishop falls
with check there's also that
so king to e1 but now just king to d4
and again there's no way you can play
some like bishop g4 we just move our own
bishop we don't care about your bishop
anymore
so here we have bishop the d1 trying to
give up some material this way
and indeed if you captured here for
example rook calculus now bishop blocks
uh
it's still you know not any of the of
the known position so white would
probably be able to draw this
although you know it's one thing to uh
said one thing to do it in practice in
the finals of the of the world cup so
you know you never know
so instead after bishop to d1 we've
kinked the e3
of course now really trying to uh
uh finish off this this white king here
uh and now
uh the the problem is you can't play
bishop captures on c2 if you could play
this it'd be great but rook g6 and
uh i mean this just wins the game
there's no way
there's no way for you to defend this if
you capture the bishop then it's
checkmate
uh and if you try king to f1 then it's
the bishop the h3 check still checkmate
you have to go to e1 and then rook to g1
is checkmate
so after king e3 we have rook captures
on c2 this has to be played
but now bishop captures uh bishop
captures and
now rook to d2 and now this is a known
winning position
and it's very very easy to win this it's
a rook against bishop and you will not
be able to
defend off i don't know if uh if there
are any that are
maybe like immediate draws but i don't
think there are so rook against bishop
you should be able to win it
so bishop to f5 we have rooked f2
attacking the bishop bishop to e6
rook to f6 we have bishop to d5 rook to
d6 now
again going after the bishop bishop to
b3
rook to b6 and now the bishop ran out of
useful squares if you move it to
anywhere other than
a2 or c2 you're gonna get checkmated or
okay d1 for that matter but that also
doesn't help you
so here bishop to c2 was played but now
just rook to a6 and he was in this
position
almost 64. that's really cool uh
alexander goriacano resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
so to give you an example if you play
something like
let's say bishop to d1 we just play rook
to a1 and you can't
save the bishop you have to move the
king we win the bishop and then of
course it's completely winning
another thing you could do is try
running away with the king but still
just
rook to a1 check king g2 and now we uh
pin the bishop that's it there
there's no escape here and another
example
you might play we tried bishop 31 you
could try kink to d1 but then just rook
to a1 check still
there's no squares for you you have to
give up the bishop this way so after
rook to a6 there really isn't anything
you can do with white and like i said it
was in this position that
alexandre gordiac resigned in the game
and the first
game of the final match of the video
women's world cup goes to alexandre
costano
so really really awesome game
congratulations on this very nice
achievement hope you guys uh enjoyed
this one so many of you have suggested
it so
i always know when you know emails start
flying in that it's going to be a great
game so thank you for that
uh i would like to thank leonard bonk uh
aberovsky david pederson jeffrey johnson
and michael hildebrand for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
uh fiji world cup checking out any
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day